auf der rückseite des mondes befindet
sich der größte erhaltene
einschlagskrater des gesamten
sonnensystems ein ort der ein
überraschendes geheimnis club denn jetzt
hat ein forschungsteam unter der
oberfläche der krater senke eine
mögliche mysteriöse masse entdeckt es
handelt sich um ein ungewöhnlich
schweres material das bis zu 300
kilometer in die tiefe reicht laut der
expertinnen und experten könnte es ein
überbleibsel eines vor rund vier
milliarden jahren eingeschlagenen nach
für ihn sein klicks um science-fiction
hier gibt's täglich fast sie mindestens
videos abonniert den kanal nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts herzlich willkommen
[Musik]
dieses mal vom evangelischen kirchentag
in dortmund wo wir hier zusammen das
erste social media die mit menschen mit
behinderung schaffen das so genannte aus
polen becken am südpol des mondes hat
wirklich gigantische ausmaße es ist mehr
als 2000 kilometer groß und im mehrere
kilometer tiefe rund vier milliarden
jahren ein gewaltiger einschlag
stattgefunden details zu diesem ereignis
sind aber bisher noch nicht bekannt und
forschungsteams weltweit sind wie genau
der einschlag auf dem noch jungen mond
ablief welche folgen er für den
erdtrabanten hatte und wie seitdem der
untergrund dieser region am mond südpol
geschaffen ist der mond über der
chinesen mit dem namen jahr da sie zwei
hatte hier vor kurzer zeit so genanntes
mantel material aufgespürt diese
entdeckung weiß aufwind dass der
einschlag vor vier milliarden jahren in
der südpol decken wohl sogar folgen für
den mond mantel hatte dieser befindet
sich zwischen mondkruste und mond kern
diesen rätseln könnten wir jetzt schritt
für schritt auf die schliche kommen ein
überraschungs von dampf aus polen becken
trägt entscheidend dazu bei unter der
oberfläche dieser krater senke befindet
sich nämlich offensichtlich eine enorme
masse anomalie
schwerefeld messung eines
forschungsteams enthüllten jetzt dass
diese massen anomalie nicht nur sehr
dicht sondern auch gewaltig schwer ist
2,18 milliarden tonnen nämlich dazu wie
james einer der beteiligten forscher
stellen sie sich vor sie würden einen
metall haufen fünfmal größer als das
amerikanische big teilen dem untergrund
vergraben
das ist ungefähr das ausmaß an
überschüssiger masse dass wir delektiert
haben
zudem reicht sie wohl bis zu 300
kilometer in die tiefe ein riesiger
metall plumpen eine unglaubliche
rohstoffquelle aufgespürt werden konnte
dieser überraschungs kunden durch die
auswertung von daten die noch bei der
grey mission gesammelt worden waren wird
zum welt steht für gravity recovery and
interior laboratory bei dieser mond
mission der nasa hat zwei sonden im jahr
2012 den mond umkreist um sein
schwerefeld zu messen
der vergleich dieser daten mit daten des
monarchen consob wird das offenbart dass
die große masse unter dem mond decken
haben südpol auf führen die fachleute
selbst kamen das völlig unerwartet die
antwort auf die entscheidende frage
allerdings ist noch völlig offen woraus
besteht diese masse an harmonie laut des
us forschungsinstituts um den metall
fern eines asteroiden handeln dazu
kinder james einen der möglichen
erklärung ist dass der metallische kern
des asteroiden der diesen krater schiff
noch immer im mantel des mondes
eingebettet
die fachleute hatten
computersimulationen durchgeführt und
damit gezeigt dass solch ein eisen
mittel kern bei einem einschlag
tatsächlich bis in den oberen monate
lang trinken könnte die fachleute
spekulieren also dass der kern des
asteroiden beim anschlag zerstört wurde
und nicht in den mond kern herabgesunken
ist sondern stattdessen im nahen mantel
verblieben ist und dies bleibt nicht
ohne folgen wie die simulationen zeigen
durch das unglaubliche gewicht des
metalls wird der grund des kraters
weiter in die tiefe gezogen um fast
einen kilometer zusätzlich doch das
alles ist bislang nur spekulation
möglicherweise könnte es sich bei der
masse anomalie natürlich auch meinen
gigantischen klumpen von oxiden handeln
metallische verbindung könnten sich dort
gesammelt haben als der mond nach seiner
entstehung nach und nach eine feste
kosten bekam die dichten oxide könnten
sich also bei der kristallisation des
lunaren magma ozean am montag gesammelt
haben fraglich ist bei dieser
interpretation jedoch warum sich der
kunden genau hier unter dem skaten
becken gebildet haben sollte gleich
werden wir die antwort auf dieses
spannende rätsel schon in wenigen jahren
bekommt denn die nächste bemannte
mond-mission ist für 2024 geplant und
die us-astronauten und astronauten
sollen tatsächlich am südpol des mondes
danken der mond seine entstehung und der
forschung anklicken anschauen und
raumzeit block der zukunft abonnieren
lohnt sich auf jeden fall bis dann bleib
dran